on va retrouver tout de suite en direct
de bruxelles notre correspondante à l'ex
le bourdon alix bonjour alors n'est pas
encore en train de parler ici en europe
d'embargo sur le gaz et le pétrole russe
on renforce ont durci les sanctions en
direction des oligarques et des et des
banques notamment
en effet un ce sont des sanctions qui
viennent s'ajouter aux trois trains de
sanctions qui ont été déjà été pris par
les européens est le but de ces
sanctions supplémentaires 1 qui ont été
adoptées ce matin à bruxelles est bien
c'est de combler les lacunes des mesures
qui ont déjà été prises et d'empêcher
les entités ciblées et vient de
contourner ces mesures déjà prises alors
les vingt-sept cible par exemple les
crypto monnaie en ça vous le savez les
pays de l'union européenne et du chai du
g7 y réfléchissent déjà depuis plusieurs
jours un pour empêcher et bien les
entités ciblé d'utiliser c'est monnaie
c'est système crypté pour contourner les
sanctions européennes notamment celles
qui vise à paralyser le secteur bancaire
et la monnaie ressemble c'est les achats
de crypto monnaie en roubles ont
justement atteint des records et puis lé
27 ont également donné leur accord pour
exclure trois banques biélorusse du
système swift est là encore un l'idée
est bien c'est d'empêcher la russie de
contourner ces mêmes mesures qui visent
justement certaines de ses banques alors
je vous rappelle que depuis l'annexion
de la crimée en 2014 l'union européenne
a déjà sanctionné 680 personnes et 53
entité est depuis fin février bien les
européens ont notamment paralysé les
actifs de la banque centrale russe
localisée hors de russie et aussi des
branches et sept banques russes du
système swift l'europe a par ailleurs
interdit son espace aérien aux
compagnies russes est également interdit
l'exportation vers la russie de
certaines technologies qui touche
notamment au secteur de l'aéronautique
mais vous l'avez dit pour le moment pas
de sanctions énergétiques comme l'ont
fait les états unis et le royaume uni
merci beaucoup